Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number and
that number is two one nine two. David P.
Hey, this is kind of a sad voicemail. Long time
adversarial caller Troy York, who calls in under
fake names all the time he left of his voicemails
are increasingly disjointed, which I know says a
lot for Troy York. He left one where it's not
even really clear what point he's making or
what he's talking about. It's kind of sad. In a
way, the trolling has gotten even less coherent.
Speaker 7: David Pakman Coleman and
the fake numbers are provided and
manipulated to go after Republican politicians.
Speaker 1: There's no evidence of that whatsoever.
Speaker 7: Plain and simple, as we
see with this garbage, with the media
constantly attacking Ron DeSantis in Florida.
Speaker 1: Remember, Florida is reporting numbers
under Republican Governor Ron DeSantis, the
idea that the Left is reporting fake Florida
numbers to make him look bad. It's the DeSantis
Department of Health and DeSantis appointees that
are all involved in managing the numbers that
are reported. This is an incoherent allegation,
Speaker 7: and this is Ryan Bosworth
Speaker 1: calling. This is not Ryan
Bosworth. This is Troy York, of course.
Speaker 7: Jacksonville, Florida. And if
you're so smart, why don't you run for
governor in Florida or non-sequitur?
Speaker 1: Completely irrelevant?
Speaker 7: Why don't you
run for president in 2024?
Speaker 1: Wasn't born in the U.S. not eligible
to be president? What a bizarre and sad downfall
of Troy York. He's some we haven't played a Troy
York voicemail for a while, but he's sometimes
leaving three or four or five voicemails a day,
all under supposedly different names, some of
them criticizing me for things I haven't said. I
think he's confusing this show with a different
show. But a sad state of affairs for Troy or
hope. We hope he does better. We've got a great
bone to show for you today. There's a hospital
that is saying it will be denying transplants to
unvaccinated people in almost all situations. Can
they do this legally? And what are the details we
will discuss? Also, the U.S. federal government
has ordered Google to identify every single person
who searched a sexual assault victim's name,
address and telephone number on
the internet. They want to do this
for investigative purposes. Is it legal, though?
We will talk about it. And a third Sandy Hook
parent has won a defamation lawsuit against
conspiracy theorist Alex Jones from Infowars.
We'll talk about the repercussions and what is
going to happen next. All of those stories and
more on today's bonus show. Get instant access
to the bonus show by becoming a member. Join
Pacman dot com or becoming a patron at Patriot
Unidentified: Icon slash David Pakman.